خلال السنوات الاخيره عززت ايران بشكل
متسارع من قدراتها الصاروخيه وتحديدا
الصواريخ بعيده المدى على الجانب الاخر
جاءت الضربات الاسرائيليه الاخيره لتكشف
تحول في اولويات تل ابيب من وقف برنامج
طهران النووي للحد من قدرتها الصاروخيه
وتحديدا الصواريخ بعيده المدى هذا تحديدا
بعدما ارسلت الوكلائها في سوريا ولبنان
اجزاء وقطع من هذه الصواريخ للوقوف على
ابعاد هذا التحول الاستراتيجي في السياسه
الامنيه الاسرائيليه اكثر معنى السيده
مايكل ايزن ستاد مدير برنامج الدفاع
والامن في معهد واشنطن للدراسات الشرق
الادنى اولا مصر مايكل اهلا بك معنا في
عسكري تاريا بدايه لماذا كل هذا التخوف
الاسرائيلي من برنامج ايران للصواريخ
وتحديدا الصواريخ بعيده المدى
الصواريخ لديها القدره على التسبب في
اضرار هائله في اسرائيل وهي قادره ايضا
على ان تطول اسرائيل انطلاقا من ايران وان
تضرب اهدافا محدده واسرائيل بلد صغير
منشاته الحساسه كتلك الخاصه بتوليد الطاقه
صغيره للغايه بالتالي لدى ايران القدره
على التسبب بضمار هائل لو استخدمت
صواريخها كما تسعى ايران الى تزويد هذه
القدرات الى الكثير من وكلائها في المنطقه
وبالتالي فهي تهدد بطريقه غير مباشره ايضا
اسرائيل التي تحاول تعطيل شحن هذه
الصواريخ او مكوناتها الى اذرع ايران
الاقليميين لحمايه نفسها وتفادي التعرض
لاي اضرار او مواجهه اي صراع في المستقبل
لما يمثله ذلك من مخاطر جمه للاسرائيليين
والضمار الكبير الذي يترتب على ذلك
مصر مايكل المنشات الصاروخيه تختلف كثيرا
عن المنشات فهي منشات ظاهره ومعروف
مواقعها الى حد كبير لكن برايك هل هذا
سيشجع الجانب الاسرائيلي على مزيد من
استهداف مثل هذه المواقع في العمق
الايراني
لقد حدث تحول في السنوات الاخيره في
استراتيجيه اسرائيل التي بدلا من التركيز
على الاهداف في بلاد الشام اي في سوريا
لان لبنان يمثل خطا احمر بسبب وجود حزب
الله لكنها تعمل على منع وصول الاسلحه
لحزب الله ايضا حولت اسرائيل تركيزها
باتجاه ايران لانها ادركت انها لن يكون
بوسعها تجاهل التطورات الحاصله في ايران
في مجال انتاج المسيرات التي يمكن ان
تستهدف اسرائيل من بلاد الشام الى جانب
تهديد الذي يمثله برنامج ايران نووي الذي
لا يواجه اي قيود في الوقت الراهن لذلك
فاسرائيل تسعى الى تعطيل هذه الانشطه فضلا
عن العمل على اطاله امد تطويرها
مستر مايكل ايران اعلنت مؤخرا انها حظائر
لطائرات تحت الارض لكن برايك هل ستنجح
ايران في اخفاء هذه المواقع عن اعين
الاستخبارات الامريكيه والاسرائيليه ام
ستنجح اجهزه الاستخبارات للولايات المتحده
وكذلك لاسرائيل في الوصول لمواقع هذه
الحظائر
ايران
لدى ايران برنامج طويل المدى خاص بتوفير
الحمايه لمنشاتها النوويه والصاروخيه
وعندما يتم حفر مخابئ للمنشات في باطن
الارض فهذا العمل بحد ذاته يبعث باشارات
والمرشح جدا انه لدى الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل معلومات جيده بشان اماكن هذه
المنشات وليس كلها وعند معرفه هذه المواقع
تبحث مساله اختيار السلاح المناسب لضربها
لكن المشكله تكمن في ان بعض المنشات
الايرانيه مثل محطه فوردو ومنشات تصنيع
الصواريخ تقع في عمق الارض تحت طبقات من
الخرسانه السميكه لكن ثمه طرق الحق اضرار
بهذه المنشات بدلا من اختراق تحصيناتها
العميقه فلو قطعت امدادات الطاقه عن مراكز
الطرد المركزي فانها يمكن ان تدمر نفسها
بنفسها في حال نفذ الهجوم بطريقه معينه
وهذا احد السبل الكفيله بالحاق الضرر بهذه
المنشات وايران على درايه بهذه المعطيات
وهو ما قد يكون قد دفعها لتطوير قدرات في
مجال الطاقه بعيده عن منشات تخسيب
اليورانيوم الامر يخص تغيرا مستمرا في
الموازنه بين مسعى ايران لحمايه قدراتها
ومنشاتها وحرص كل من الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل على ان تظل هذه القدرات
والمنشاءات ضعيفه
مصر مايكل دائما بعد كل عمليه تستهدف
منشات ايرانيه تتحدث الاجهزه الامنيه في
ايران عن انها سترد لكن على ارض الواقع لا
ترد باي شيء هل لدى ايران خيارات فعليه
للرد ام انه مثل هذه الاحاديث التي تخرج
من النظام هي مجرد دعايه اعلاميه لا اكثر
ولا اقل
نستطيع باعتقادي القول ان ايران حاولت
الرد لكن حتى الان حققت اسرائيل الكثير من
النجاحات في احباط محاولات رد الايرانيه
ومن وجهه النظر الايرانيه ثمه مخاطر تكمن
في التصعيد مع اسرائيل وقد شهدنا في
الاونه الاخيره تغيرا في تركيز ايران على
استهداف الجنود الامريكيين في العراق لما
يسببه هذا التوجه من تعطيل لمنظومه الحكم
في العراق كما تغير تركيزها على استهداف
ما يزعم انها منشات اسرائيليه في شمال
العراق او حتى الاهداف الكرديه لكن تحول
ايران احيانا استهداف الامريكيين عندما
ترى ان الولايات المتحده لن ترد على هذا
الاستهداف عكس ما تتوقعه من اسرائيل
والهجمات على الجنود الامريكيين في سوريا
ترى فيها ايران ضغوطا تمارس على اسرائيل
تحاول ايران ايجاد سبل للرد لك اعتقد انها
نجحت في هذه المسائل
مستر مايكل بعد كل هذه السنوات هل نستطيع
القول بان واشنطن اخطات خطا استراتيجيا
حينما لم تضع قيود على برنامج ايران
للصواريخ الباليستيه وما هو السبيل لعلاج
هذه المشكله بشكل او باخر
اعتقد اننا حاولنا خلال مفاوضات مع ايران
بشان ملف النووي وضع قيود على قدرات ايران
الصاروخيه لكن بالنسبه لايران تمثل
الصواريخ العمود الفقري لقواتها
الاستراتيجيه فقد شهدنا انها قد تقبل
قيودا على برنامجها النووي وليس على
البرنامج الصاروخي ربما قد يقال اننا لم
نسعى بما فيه الكفايه او نول الاولويه
لهذا المساء غير انني لا اعتقد ان ايران
كانت ستقبل بوضع اي قيود على برنامجها
الصاروخي بالتالي تبقى الخيارات المتاحه
للتعامل مع هذا البرنامج تقتصر على تعطيل
البرنامج وتخريبه وهو ما سعت كل من
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل الى القيام به
حينما احرز من تقدم في هذا الاتجاه ليس
بالقدر الكبير خاصه في مجال تصنيع ايران
للصواريخ البالستيه بعيده المدى
مستر مايكل مؤخرا تزايدت تدريبات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه التي تحاكي هجوم
على منشات ايران انا وياه برايك هل مثل
هذه المناورات ستشكل قوه رضع بالنسبه
لايران ام انها ستمنح النظام الايراني
فرصه لوجود بدائل او لايجاد بدائل اخرى
اعتقد ان المناورات الاخيره التي كانت
الاكبر من نوعها بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل على الاطلاق ربما تعكس القلق لدى
البلدين بان البرنامج النووي الايراني لم
يتوقف وعلى الولايات المتحده واسرائيل ان
تجد سبلا للتصدي لتهديد النووي الايراني
واقناعها بضروره الحد من انشطتها النوويه
والعدول عن مواصله تخصيب اليورانيوم حتى
درجه نقاء تصل الى 90% بعد ان بلغت نسبه
60% والمناورات تعد جزء منها رادعه ولد
البلدين الرغبه في رؤيه ما سيكون عليه
الرد الايراني كما ان الولايات المتحده
سوف تجري مناورات مع حلفائها وشركائها
الاقليميين وقد نشهد ايضا مناورات بين
الولايات المتحده ودول عربيه واسرائيل في
المستقبل لتوجيه رساله الى ايران مفادها
ان ما تقوم به ايران من انشطه يقوض
مصالحنا وسوف نعمل على الاخلال بالوضع
الامني في ايران
مصر مايكل ايزون ستاد مدير برنامج الدفاع
والامن في معهد واشنطن للدراسات الشرق
الادنى شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التوضيحات